Harry Styles
this was Harry's house more than a
decade on from The X Factor now at the
top of his game taking all four of the
awards he was nominated for including
the big one this night has been really
really special to me and I will never
forget it thank you so much for the
welcome home I appreciate it so much
there is no place I come
from Sam Smith and Kim Petrus and
erotically charged performance the
desire to ensure non-binary artists like
Smith aren't excluded a driving pattern
behind the Brits dropping its gendered
category
well this is all male best artist
shortlist called controversy from Styles
it's winner and acknowledgment of the
women noticeably absent and very aware
of my privilege up here tonight so this
award is for arena Charlie Florence
Mabel and Becky thank you so much
[Music]
talented female musicians out there from
the Isle of wight's finest a Brit's
performance that couldn't be more
British earworms like this a key driver
behind Indie Duo wet legs two wins
that rock and roll
it just won't go away the one and only
Harry Styles
but this was Harry's night a
semi-permanent fixture on the stage I'm
so proud to be here tonight celebrating
British arts and British music
conversation going into this stars is
full winds victory for an artist intent
on blurring gender lines and rallying
against toxic masculinity
news
[Applause]